burgers semester it was going to be here
for it and so in a way so I'm going to
speak again about context reality sort
of in following in line from a co a
stock and sort of this resource theory
part is to try to connect to the topic
of the workshop and the tours is sort of
to let me get away with not quite okay
so i guess this so so i'll go quickly
drew introduction because Co has already
and introduced the idea that the main
idea is contextual at the end of these
formalism and so why were interesting
contextual it is because it's a
fundamental non-classical phenomenon of
quantum mechanics and what I what I is
the word phenomenon I really mean it so
it's not a property of the theory but
he's actually they can deduce from
observable some things you can observe
in nature and that quantum mechanics
does predict ok so in recent years
there's been a couple of papers came out
so suggesting that context reality could
be thought of as a resource for certain
quan computation tasks so these are two
papers that curry also mentioned so i
won't go much into it and the again my
talk is sort of part of these so i use
the this framework for context reality
introduced by samson and by adam
brandenburger which gives a unified and
general framework to talk about katek
shoe a lity and nonlocality in general
management scenarios and i'm going to
talk about some compositional aspects
are to compose measurement scenarios and
and and empirical models i need to
particularly think about free operation
so operations that student in greece
context reality and also moreover in
this framework there's this qualitative
notion of so this quality vieira key of
notions of context reality like logical
context reality strong collects
royalties esco he presented and part of
what we're doing in this work instead of
getting a quantity of grading for this
thing and sort of introducing something
that could be solved as a measure of how
much context chirality a certain
empirical model this place so we'll
introduce the contextual fraction and
it's it's a measure of context to ality
that satisfy the number of desirable
properties so first it's general so it's
applicable to any measurement scenario
you'll always have a value between 0 & 1
& 0 will correspond to non contextual
so no contexto allottees presents and
one who correspond to this from context
relatives of the strongest notion of
context reality that Co he presented so
we can compute it with linear
programming so it's quite easy to
compute and it has precise relationship
with violations of Bell inequalities and
we're over this monitor and with respect
to a number of operations that I'll
discuss and it also relates to
quantifiable quantifiable advantages in
certain rotation or quantum information
processing tests okay so quickly go
introduce the idea of good radio
contexto ality and so we sort of the
framework we we have is we consider
[Music]
scenarios where you can perform certain
measurements and observe the outcomes so
probably see how it comes with these
things so it is the simplest now you can
think about you have Alice and Bob Alice
can perform one of two measurements I'll
call them a1 and a2 both can perform one
to two measurements we wanted me to and
each of these measurements is either
back atomic measurement so as outcomes
01 and once if you if you perform all
the possibilities of running this
experiment you end up with a table like
that right where each each row
corresponds to one context so two on
compatible choice of measurements so
once I to measure Morales and what for
Bob and each column corresponds to the
possible joint outcomes and then so each
row should be a problem distribution of
these joint outcomes so in general
you stand there all the time so in
general you have a measurement scenario
we'll have we have a set of measurements
and a set of possible outcomes oh and
then we have a cover effect so this game
is a cover of X is just a set of sets of
measurements which are emitted which are
what we call context and they're the
measurement that can be performed
together and that therefore should have
joint values and you can observe these
joint values and so these is a piggly
example where you have these four
measurements and the contexts are the
ones where you choose one for a lease on
one for Bob and then you have possible
events which is so did this event
corresponds to Alice choosing to measure
a one Bob choosing to measure B 1 and
day observing 0 1 respectively ok so
there's another example in it so an
empirical model will be will then be
just a family of probability
distributions one for each context or
one for each set of compatible
measurements and these so we require
these distributions satisfy the
following compatibility condition which
is the local consistency part of this
which is that they agree on overlap so
whenever two contexts overlap the
probability situation should marginalize
the same thing this is what is usually
called no sailing one we're talking
about multipartite scenarios ok so then
contacts quality sort of question one
asks then is we have a bunch of probably
distributions that agree on overlaps is
there a joint probability distribution
on all the measurements so on all under
joint outcomes for all the measurements
in the system that wants marginalized to
each context gives back the probably
solution you're talking about and so so
can we glue these local information into
the persistent global distribution and
so when we can't do that we said where
we have contextual ax t
okay okay in particular to play the
stronger the quality we should like Ohio
already mentioned is when there is at a
possibly seek level there's not even one
assignment there's not no consistent
assignments of outcomes to all the
measurements so you could imagine that
you have some assignments of outcomes to
all the measurements that are consistent
with part of the model but in so in this
case it means that there is no so
whatever global assignments you consider
there will be one context where the
restriction of these global assignments
is a sign probability zero so it's not
in the support of the problem
distribution so it cannot occur so okay
so then so these modifies the
introduction of this idea of the
contextual fraction and so again so non
conjecture ality we are asking for a
global distribution that restricts to
all these local distributions and so the
question is which fraction so if we
can't achieve that we can ask which
fraction of the model does still admit
an architectural explanation so we could
consider so instead of asking for a
global problems distribution we just ask
for a sub distribution so it doesn't
have to some to sort of the values
analysis i'm 21 and we so we ask for a
sub distribution whose marginals to each
context will be less than or equals of
point-wise done the the distribution we
have at each context and the noncontact
refraction will be the maximum weight of
such sub distribution global so
distribution so equivalently we could we
could we could think so what we doing is
taking our empirical models or a set of
local probable distributions and they
complain writing it as a convex
combination as convex composition into a
non contextual model and some other
model and we asking for what is the
maximum weight we can give the reason on
contextual part and
will happen that whenever you do that
the resulting so so whenever you
maximize is lambda these other
contextual model will actually be
strongly contextual so in fact we can
always write any model as a convex the
composition of a non contextual in the
strong get actual model and the weight
that you give to an architectural model
is already called an architectural
fraction and the 1 minus lambda is all
we call the contextual fraction okay
yeah so i'll write ncf and CF for these
things so so just to mention so i won't
go into details about these but to
mention that this one for this easily
computable using a by solving these this
particular linear program okay so it's
just some lots of the actual production
for four different models to come from
quantum mechanics and we we can produce
using Mathematica and okay so now how
does this relate to violations of bo
inequalities so Bellamy qualities are
sort of the inequalities are
characterized the polytope of non
contextual models and and sold yet so
the idea so so I I'll give a very
general idea of what this is so Samson
in his lectures at the start of the
semester sort of introduced and by this
set of formulas that were not that you
couldn't jointly satisfy and therefore
that sort of implies a certain
inequality but so I'll forget about how
they come about but the ideas that you
have some sort of linear inequalities we
have some sort of coefficients that you
put two on each of the elements of the
table and so an inequality will be just
some linear inequality on that table and
this is a determined Western
coefficients in a certain bound and what
we care about is so we don't also
general to actually take the band to be
0 but I change the coefficient slightly
but we'll call this a bell inequality
when it's satisfied by every non
contextual model and in particular is
tight if if it's saturated by if there
is an architectural model or saturated
and so desire to sort of the linear
inequalities I've determine what iron
architectural models and a model would
be not good actual if it satisfies all
such Melanie colleges okay okay so
abellia call this necklace so I called
establishes a bound for the value of
these pieces left hand side after Bell
inequality right amongst all non
effectual models but no signal models in
general can violate these contextual
models will violate Bell inequalities
and in general so this is the expression
for what is the maximum value of the
left hand side of this inequality for a
general Nasiri model and so we need
these two sort of normalize the
violation of a bell inequality so given
a model we so instead of talking about
by how much does it violate a certain
bella equality we normalize these value
by the maximal violation that's
permitted by a knowingly model and the
idea is to be able to compare across
compare violations across different
scenarios where and the cosecant
inequality
sort of gives you an idea of the extent
to which a certain model violates a
certain Bell inequality and so what's
the relation between the contextual
fraction and violations of our
inequality is the following so if you
have any protocol model then the
normalized violation of any Bell
inequality will be at most a contextual
fraction of these empirical model
moreover there will be a bell in
equality whose normalized violation will
be exactly these the contextual fraction
so these boundaries attained there is
well in quality for which this bone is
attained and moreover these inequality
will be tight at the non contextual part
of the model and will be maximally
violated by the strongly contextual part
of the model and when I have these
inverted commas around there because
there's not necessarily a unique
decomposition but for any decomposition
these will be true okay and you can find
in particular can find these Bell
inequality that attains its maximum by
just do the dual linear program of the
program we had before okay so much time
ok so now so change gear a little bit
and we'll talk about some operations you
can you can do on empirical models and
so the motivation for this is that there
might be more than one possible measure
one or more possible ways of measuring a
text reality and so one should think
about what what conditions should a good
measure of context reality satisfy and
one thing that I should do it goes
should be monitoring with respect to
operations that don't introduce context
reality and and so and this would be
sort of the three operations in a
resource theory of contextual T so sort
of in sort of akin to the resource
theories exist for entanglement like
Locke and for not
okay so we'll consider certain
operations of empirical models which we
should think about has non non really
increasing context to ala T and so so
just this is a notation I use so x moi
sort of this one specifies our
measurement scenario and when I right
ecole an xml means that there's an
empirical model of these types or
empirical model for this measurement
scenario and you'll see that the
operations that are present sort of
remind one of the operations you see in
process algebra we urge the exception of
one but anyway so what what are the
operations so the first of them is
relating so you could you could relate
so we have a bye Jackson between the
yeah if you have empirical model on this
measurement scenario and you have
another measurement scenario which is
sort of where the measurements are in a
bijection then you could just real able
it and physical model these madmen
scenario so that's quite simple the
other thing is restrictions so if you
have a smaller measurement scenario so
you consider a smaller set of
measurements and a smaller set of
contacts in the sense that so did so so
this doesn't need to be necessarily the
restriction of this context to those but
it so anything that's compatible in the
smaller model should also be compatible
in a larger model so it should just
marginalize the bigger one similarly you
can cause grain the output so you could
apply some function to the outputs and
which corresponds to some coarse
graining and then so the more
interesting ones will be these three
which sort of combine two different two
beautiful models so given to empirical
models on the same scenario you could
consider mixing them so she's just
defined by a convex combination of the
two ish context
then you have this choice thing so the
idea here is you have to empirical model
some two different measurement scenarios
and the idea is that you'll just put
them side by side so you'll consider so
the new set of measurements are is the
de jong union of the two sides of
measurements they should be explained
but there's no no extra compatibilities
are introduced right so you either you
lie to perform the measurements on the
first measurement scenario to resonance
of the second measurement scenario and
then so the more interesting one is a
tensor which sort of I guess relates to
what Berlin was talking yesterday in
sort of a related with different
formalism but the idea here is that you
have two empirical models one in two
different measurement scenarios and
you're not considered a measurement
scenario where we should be which
combine these two measurement scenarios
and you think of it as a sort of Alice
and Bob so Alice has access to the first
measurement scenario in Baba's Alice to
the second mission scenario and you can
do so it's they did they sort of act
independently so you can you can ask
so what what either compatible the
compatible measurement took at the
compatible sort of the resulting context
or the compatible sets of measurements
will be always choose the compatible set
of measurements to perform and Bob
chooses another compatible server
measure to perform and any any such
choice is will be a compatible
measurement into the resulting scenario
for us what is so if you think of these
as simplicial complexes is a simplicial
join up to simplicial complexes right so
that the resulting context are the joint
unions of context from one scenario the
other one and then the the probability
distributions are just product
probability distributions so the idea is
that the two things are happening
independently for Allison football and
and if you think about all of these
operations should never should never
introduced any extra context reality so
learning the three from the previous
slide are just real labelings and of
course screenings these one is sort of
the two things are happening don't even
interact for these one here you have I
mean you can certainly a big a mesma
scenario but you sort of have a product
state so the idea is that so if you
think about in in quantum mechanics is
sort of correspond if these would be
Stacy sorta corresponds to the product
state so the idea so you always have
these projects creations so you're not
introducing any extra correlations
between Alice and Bob and and the mixing
you're just making things so you
shouldn't you can't create any extra it
can technology so you
what happens with respect to contextual
how does the contextual fraction
behavioral respect to these operations
then okay so this is obvious for these
ones if you just do a relabeling which
is by ejection then you don't change the
context refraction but these are the two
you could only you could only decrease
the contextual fraction because you
forgetting information in general then
from mixing then so the contextual
fraction of a convex combination of
scenarios will be smaller or equal than
the convex combination of the contextual
fraction so this means that contextual
fractions accuser is a convex function
and then for the choice and these tensor
operations so in terms of sort of choice
operation the resulting contextual
fraction is just going to be the maximum
of the different actual fractions or if
you think about the non context
refraction is a minimum of 22 and for
the 10 so you have this complicated
expression which is much easy it's
easier to see in terms of the non
contextual fraction which is going to be
the product of the two non-contractual
fractions and so it is an equality ok so
in particular for these three things if
you take a prime to be non contextual ie
the contextual fraction being zero then
you see that you're not injured so
you're not augmenting to contact the
amount of contact shoe ality that you
are free of composing a model with an
architectural model in any of these
three ways you should never introduce
more context royalty and indeed that's
where you find
okay so just to wrap up so I'm just
going to talk briefly about contextual
fraction quantum advantage so the idea
as I said as a context artists been
associated with some quantum advantage
in computational or information
processing tasks and part of the idea of
having a measure of context reality like
the conventional fraction is that we
should be able to quantify context
reality and to relate to so if one
quantifies these advantages in some way
then we should be able to relate the
amount of context reality to the amount
of advantage you get in these tasks so
one example is this work by Robert
rosendorf that both kohei and I
mentioned and I think that ish gave a
talk about it maybe three weeks ago
something so those of you were here will
be heard a lot about these think so what
is the idea here you have a measurement
based quanta computation scheme where
the classical control can only perform
linear operations in NZ to sew a
classical control is the thing that pre
precise is the input and post process is
the output and in between Sarah
determines the flow of computation and
so the result here and so the additional
power two components compute nonlinear
functions resides in a resource
empirical model so and the class
controls determines which measurements
is going to perform and our conversation
is going to evolve okay and what so the
result by rosendorf where's that if you
have such a an l2 embakasi so a
measurement based on kapeniak scheme of
this form that deterministically
computes a nonlinear boolean function so
in general this this is a probabilistic
computation but if it determine if it
computes a certain linear function that
it must be strong in contextual a
nonlinear function and moreover the
probability question was that if the
nonlinear function is computed with a
sufficiently large probability of
success then these implies that there is
some context reality there but you can
refine these in terms of the contextual
fraction
this is my last slide so and what you
get is the following so you can so if
you write this new F represents the
average distance between the function
that you trying to compute and the
closest linear function so itself is an
indication is a measure of how difficult
the problem is so I'll far from a linear
function this is and if i write ps4 the
probability of success then we have that
one minus PS is larger than or equal to
an architectural fraction times this
hardness so if you think about if you
fix this target function you're trying
to compute and you're trying to increase
the probability of success you see that
this left hand side will decrease and
therefore these are study creates an
architectural pressure has to decrease
so you have to use a resource with more
conjecture allottee and
in particular these gives back the the
case of stronger sexuality and before ok
cool so for a direction we should so
there's also a measure of contextual it
in terms of negative probabilities but
in particular HP bar it's a part of its
been talking about and so one question
is how these relate Saudis contextual
fracture relates to it so we know quite
a bit of that also what can you say by
signaling models and about the resource
theory so one of the operations that was
missing in there with some notion of
sequencing so we have some ideas of how
to do this but it's not quite complete
yet but you'll have to change the notion
of empirical models to include some
causal some causal structure so also
related to what chain structure
empirical models and also the question
is can we have more results of the kind
that i just presented about relating
quantum advantage and and the amount of
context reality of in a certain model
so question is it this is a metric
probably not this is a metric just what
century i started distance right so if
you think of it i mean with that number
so is so he's a number is associated to
a particular empirical model so i'm not
quite sure you mean a metric between
yeah yeah i missed 12 you talk about
linear program vice for gravity but then
you know the algebra test two percent
there were lots of non-linearity in the
compositions of it so how are these two
aspects related so so the linear
programming is about how one calculates
this contextual fraction for a given
empirical model or how one calculates
the bell inequality is going to 80 feet
is a dual program and so the idea of
this algebra is that so these are
operations you can perform any pinnacle
models and then what is my present in
the end is how the contextual fraction
behaves with respect to these operations
but uh so sort of behaves nicely with
like Special Operations it doesn't
reduce any
any
some extra faction doesn't increase when
you where you were you not quite sure
you do use so in particularly in order
to show what happens for the tensor
which is the most difficult case you do
need to use sort of the prove that an
architectural fraction he's the product
of the other two uses the linear
programming so he's the description that
linear programming to prove one of the
size of inequality and uses a dual
program to prove the other side of the
inequality absolutely sorry if you how
humble was built up you could decompose
the computation yes so if you knew if
you knew how a model is built up in
terms of these operations for example
then you could you can decompose a
computation of the comp actual fraction
by in terms of these components so if
you have to if you know the contextual
fraction of the components then you know
the context refraction okay so that's
let us stand rui'an equal to instruction
[Applause]